thank you for Sarah good morning guys
I'm happy that so many of you found
their way here after last night's party
I am heiko and I'm actually with a
company called pebble we do we are
mostly known yay rocket we are mostly
known for smartwatches so self you there
who of you knows what what peddlers and
pedal does that's that's basically
everybody who does not well they are few
okay I have a few slides for you too so
the thing you're looking at is basically
the PCP or the main board of ammo or
pebbles this is a disassembled version
of this pebble here and when I speak
about um variables I want to share the
learnings we gathered when we may
javascript running directly on our
limited hardware and I want to walk you
through some of those limitations and
then again what we learned from doing so
so again for those three or four people
who don't know pebble it is basically as
much what SmartWatch I like to think of
us as the first mover those who first
came out with a SmartWatch long before
Android wear or Apple watch and in fact
all watches work with both iOS and
Android and in officially also our
thanks to our community on other
platforms we do obviously notifications
but recently I'm we emphasize on health
to where our latest model has a built-in
hardware monitor with your step tracking
sleep tracking smart alarms that wake
you up on your own REM phase and so on
and so forth we are best known for our
long battery life for last four week
instead of a few hours and it's an
always-on display which is quite neat
but the reason why I'm here is because
it's hackable you can actually program
on it and we emphasized on a very open
API and open app approach from day one
and that led to a plethora of different
apps so there are hobbyists such as like
sailors or servers who benefit from
pebble being waterproof but they're also
big brands such as uber or nest who give
access easy access right on your wrist
to their services so with rubra for
example is really just a button press
and that taxi comes and picks you up and
there's also another category obviously
on a watch and that is watched races
there are tens of thousands watch faces
by now I'm developed by our community
and they are any media they are colorful
they are very delightful and it's great
to see that people always say that our
platform is a bit limited but it just
happened two weeks ago that a demo
classic a pc demo classic was ported to
pebble and presented at one of those
demo parties in germany and that kicked
off a conversation our community and
there's now a slight channel discussing
how we could leverage that and create a
demo scene just within papal let's all
great and amazing but traditionally on
embedded devices and pebble there's no
exception there you are forced to write
code C or C++ and sometimes and you look
at that damn or even in assembly and
that is mostly because of that Audra
being so limited space wise and also
performance wise which is a bummer
because see sometimes looks like this
and that is great see actually I looked
it up in on a blog post and he walks us
through this piece of code that does
what exactly who can tell me what it
does shrink incarnation yeah that's true
i mean the function name sure obviously
states that right it takes basically an
array of strings and concatenate that
into a buffer see has no concept of a
string and you have to allocate the
buffer before and tell it how long the
buffer is the counterpart in javascript
would look like that maybe like you have
an array of strings and you join them
together i'm pretty sure there are other
ways to do it but this is pretty neat
isn't it now what stops us from doing
that there are plenty of other devices
that do I'm JavaScript on there and they
are all embedded I did a quick research
to find some of those and this is the
list that came up with I'm pretty sure I
missed some and my apologies for this
but I just want to put things in
perspective here and to do that I picked
some arbitrary metric here the amount of
available realm of those different
devices and if you look at int'l addison
or the rest
hi they have one gigabyte of RAM which
is basically not a limited and better
device anymore that's a real computer
and then there's the omega 2 and there's
the tassel and they are more within the
range of 64 megabytes and if you think
about it booting a Linux for example and
that environment is already other tricky
but it's certainly doable and then there
are others s Perino like I'm by Gordon
Williams for example he kick started on
this grade embedded device that does
nothing but runs java script and how
much room do they have why don't they
have any well the problem is scale here
and I try another attempt here gigabyte
is far too large and I'm scaling that
down to 64 megabytes and if i zoom in
and zoom further and zoom further I
finally find asbury no pico with 96 k
and pebble offering only 64 kilobytes of
RAM to applications 64 kilobytes
compared to those 64 megabytes that's a
fraction of 1024 of that other amount
like that's tiny and I understand that
this is hard to understand so I will try
once more this is the J's compiler and
website and you see that I'm little icon
at the top left that's an SVG that file
is 25k large as we G is known to be very
concise in this particular case because
it is actually I'm a bit curved maybe it
is not optimal for SVG but it's pretty
small the pixel data on my laptop on
this particular screen shot though takes
already up more space than the 64 K
available on pebble for applications
just to prevention perspective so it's
not only it's in fact Lee the code is
not only JavaScript but actual data and
all of that needs to live on that
computer things are not that bad though
because people already build great
things we know that you can accomplish
something so well let's do it so there
plenty of JavaScript engines right we
take one of those I again yesterday run
a quick test and I'm loaded google com
on my Chrome browser and it took 150 5
megabytes or I looked at the engine
itself which is yet another number
if even if we had a JavaScript engine
it's somewhat would take up code space
on our flesh like on our firmware and we
before we started this endeavor we
figured that we would have 200k worth of
code space flash code space something
you would normally not even think about
when you do right development and and
phantom jas which is basically a
headless browser based on javascriptcore
already takes out 32 megabytes so this
is way out of reach and when we
presented internally in the sand pebble
the idea to run an interpreter and even
JavaScript and I'll pebble watches they
thought we were crazy like this is not
possible it will not run at all and we
still said we want that we want that so
deeply because the workflow in C is
outdated it takes like 20 seconds for
turnaround when you do like pizza not
some things you need to compile and need
to deploy and then you look at it and
you already forgot how the previous
version looked like I want to have fresh
tooling as it's common in the JavaScript
world I want to have the ability to to
benefit from you the community all these
NPM packages all the knowledge that's
there I want to go to second flow and
quickly copy and paste something and run
it all now watch well luckily there are
other JavaScript engines out there meant
for embedded devices I think the most
prominent one is called duck tape that
tape is taking a few hundred K of code
space you could probably squeeze it down
then there's obviously as Perino Jerry
script I'm very interesting project
kinoma looks also very promising and
then there is I like similar to any
other JavaScript library out there every
week pops up another JavaScript engine
basically so here are if you the problem
with those tiny i would say hobby
attempts is that there are oftentimes
not standard compliant or like by far
future complete so in the end we decided
to go with javascript and when Gordon
Williams from spree no actually asked me
I came up with that list here and it's
basically first and foremost Jerry
script
the Melbourne source obviously but this
one here has a great team behind it
full-time people working on this for
over a year now which is amazing because
we have to stand on the shoulders of
giants here we can I do that all
ourselves but it's also standard
compliance or whatever you do whatever
you do in valid JavaScript will actually
run on the watch and that is critical
because otherwise it's yet another
script language that is Travis would
look alike but not the real thing and
overall it's just the quality of the
project communication architecture all
of it + partners that contribute to it
as we do so that's great and I think it
took us so we first did in a screen of
port and that ran on the watch and then
we did Jerry script again and it was
early May when we finally shipped
JavaScript on the watch so those people
in the audience you actually were a
pebble if you go to the standard watch
face take talk the one with the two
hands that is already running JavaScript
without you knowing it we ship the
JavaScript engine we re implemented our
standard watch face we have integration
tests to make sure that it's pixel
perfectly the same and it doesn't
consume more battery as the sea
counterpart did and we shipped it now
that was easy the hard part and the
stuff I want to talk about is our
learnings when we finally made that
available to developers which is also
happen happening right now actually and
the three things i want to focus on our
api's memory constraints sorry bear with
me but memory is really critical in our
platform and then launch time something
that isn't really obvious if you think
of it about it for the first time so
api's i was talking about javascript
what javascript by itself doesn't do
much again here's our board there's the
CPU as the MCU which combines different
components in our case the CPU and RAM
and JavaScript what can you actually do
with it I mean in the standard that
state there are regular expressions
different things in the standard but you
cannot even log anything because
console.log is not part of the standard
so just having JavaScript by itself
is actually bit useless we want to give
access to everything our platform
delivers and that is way more so here is
a teardown of the actual watch this is
not too different boards at the bottom
you see the flip side of the same bored
so it's mirrored and the MCU is really
just that's JavaScript that's grounded
but there is also flash storage that is
where we store the program and store
your bid maps and other resources like
custom fonts that is obviously the
ePaper display you want to show
something on the screen and battery so
that if you happen to be a taxi service
you could check the battery level and if
it's critical you could raise the fare
like there are real use cases for access
to the battery and then there is also
all the sensors and the Bluetooth radio
you want to talk to your phone you want
to talk to the Internet how would we
possibly make that accessible the
problem with AP is on our end is unlike
a library and API developer who does the
next library and publish it as
publishers it on NPM is that we cannot
really do semantic versioning raise the
major version number and break
everything that was ever there because
developers are using our SDK submit this
to the App Store and consumers run
whatever version of the firmware there
is actually the problem that once we
commit to an API we more or less have to
support it forever and that is really a
delicate problem as an API designer
because we don't have the luxury to
write api's here we are much more in the
in the shoes of a browser vendor here
and that's actually the key to the story
there are standardized a B is for all of
these problems and you know them they
are called web AP is so although we are
running on this tiny embeddable embedded
hardware we chose to look at the at the
browsers and learn from them and
basically re-implemented what they did
so for for the display for example we
chose canvas and it's ugly as hell and
it's really inconvenient to use but it's
a standard and that means others know
how to use it they know the clip falls
and there are already solutions to the
problems that come with it there's a
contract we can commit to and we know
that they will not change well at least
not that frequently and similarly for
communication between the phone and the
watch our way our dead greater the
internet we chose a post message as you
would talk to another window or a
background worker and then use an event
system for four different occurrences in
the system so that is all great and it
lab together with NPM to a very concise
way to writing applications so this is a
very minimal way of writing apps you can
actually use NPM packages and with that
we hope that people write Poli filled
and and create other convenience
functions but this is also the way to
get access to the rude object of our API
we called it rocky as in like stones and
pebble you know and that rocky global
allows you to register like to listen to
events such as when it has to draw
itself the system could ask for it to
draw at any time because of different
like events in the system and the web
api is being so flexible allow us to
also add a new proprietary events such
as a minute change when you write a
watch face for example it's not really
feasible to redraw every second because
that drains the battery if you really
only want to update once a minute it's
also hard to do the date math with just
the building data object you could
totally do that you could query for the
current time and then the right set
timeout and then a schedule at redraw
but we actually provide a convenient
events for this like minute change
second change so let you know on the
edge when the minute changes that you
can redraw so that's it pretty neat but
with those standard api's we also
created some expectations so canvas is
pretty powerful and some of its
implementations for example clipping to
a path is difficult to implement an all
platform a naive and very um performant
efficient solution would be to store a
binary mask actually like an alpha
channel
to tear to measure what is actually
masked out but such an alpha channel is
already on our platform like 6k worth of
data and we are ready short ram and then
other things as i mentioned before and
cameras are not really convenient
especially if you come from our capi
where we tailored towards the need of a
watch face developer yes angles are
rotated clockwise but they start at 3pm
which is very inconvenient if you want
to do hands and they all start at twelve
o'clock and then also drawing a simple
line means yeah you put in a path you
move to something you line to something
and then you stroke instead of just a
plain line call so yeah that is odd but
it's just the standard what we figured
is that and we talked to the community
on that we cannot ship all of this at
once what we did instead is we [ __ ] what
we have we know I'm what the target is
because it's just the web AP eyes and
just like fail with exceptions when I
function is undefined that allows
developers to create polyfills and it's
actually better to have something now
than to wait another half a year
something until we finally did this so
I'm also interested in your feedback on
this so yeah with that we basically
shipped api's let's talk about memory
constraints so there are like when you
talk about size and JavaScript you
oftentimes think about transfer like how
much how many bytes you need to transfer
from the web server to my browser in
order to deliver content how can I get
the first flight to the browser earliest
how can i leverage caches but this is
actually pretty meaningless so this one
is a demo it's a not sure I've seen this
but there's a competition very much like
the demo scene in general it's basically
how much cool effects can you squeeze
into 1k worth of JavaScript so let me
again I'm not sure why it's done right
here actually so yeah that is a 1k of
JavaScript the JavaScript looks like rap
it's it's concise yeah it's only 1k for
those of you who cannot read gibber ish
what's actually happening here is that
there is a compressed string the actual
payload is almost 2k worth of JavaScript
source code and then this is the loop at
the end we uncompress it into a variable
and then we'ii valid so basically
instead of running one carriage of
JavaScript we are running almost 2k of
JavaScript so one could think that we
just expanded it well one hundred
percent and at runtime we need 2k worth
of RAM right well I took the numbers
again on Chrome and it's more like half
a gigabyte roughly and of course this is
like comparing apples with oranges here
because the browser itself takes up RAM
and the GPU process the rendering
pipeline here has a lot of overhead for
this particular use case and we could
make that way more concise but this is
really just to put things in perspective
code size 1k has nothing to do with
runtime requirements how much RAM you
actually have and I would say that you
guys have no idea about ram or could you
tell me how much RAM this object
actually takes like you javascript has
no concept of an out of memory situation
you can always just create a string you
can always just create an object but
what if you run out of RAM what this
does not happen in your environment so
here for example you need actually
character space to store the property
name you need space to store the
original string you need more space to
store the concatenated string to store 0
which is living on the context how much
is a string worth is it really stored as
utf-16 do you know what says ooh ay tis
and their way to encode um emojis
because they don't fit into the unicode
plane of you
of unicode 16 like how much cash do they
actually do in order to look at the
property do they have like a hashmap for
the string look up probably we do so
it's really tough to tell let's say like
conservatively on v8 maybe that is I
don't know 32 byte probably not maybe 64
byte if you store 10 of those it's
already 640 bites that's like in the
range of something you are you can
notice on our platform so we rode I'm a
couple of tools to analyze byte code to
analyze heat consumptions but we quickly
realize that this is not the level a
typical JavaScript developer want to
operate on so what we did instead is
reintroduced an event oftentimes it's
basically going like this i program my
program i program until this is not
enough ram anymore and then it crashes
well that's great but I could actually
prepare for this scenario if you are
like like memory leaks are one thing but
often times you have structures that
could be recreated if you have had more
RAM later on so what we do is I'm we
actually I'm firing event when you have
high memory pressure and then you could
lose of resources you don't need anymore
and there's another occasion when this
event fires and that it's really the
critical piece and when if you don't let
lose now we actually quit your
application what interesting question is
how would you possibly do any logic here
if you're out of RAM anyway so let's
talk about performance then luckily
Jerry script unlike other embedded
runtime such as Perino as Breen who
actually parses the same source code
again and again if you jump into a
function that parses that function again
if you jump out and jump in to get it
parses it again javascript is way more
efficient it stores a code in byte code
and that is great but computing bytecode
upfront costs time and RAM and hence you
know it by now we don't have that Ram so
what we did come up with is a system
where we produced by code offline you
have your own program stored in the
folder structure our SDK bundles
JavaScript for the phone and JavaScript
for the watch and it also compresses
some of the resources and then if you
install
application we actually move the
JavaScript part to the phone that was
already true for the last two years and
now the crazy thing happens words were
you called JavaScript inception
internally we basically cross compile
the JavaScript compiler using Emscripten
to JavaScript so that we can take your
JavaScript and produce JavaScript byte
code in JavaScript and that is for
different reasons one of them is that
the bytecode is no real maybe I contract
it actually depends on the firmware but
on iOS for example you cannot download
any new executable code unless it's
JavaScript so and there are different
other reasons and I'd love to talk about
it but in the end we actually only store
the bytecode on the watch executed in
the JavaScript environment point for is
what we were talking about here and then
you have access to the API talk to the
internet and everything that is crazy
but we did it we ship that like one and
a half weeks or two we finally make that
available to developers and this is how
it looks like so in the shell you have
this SDK thing you can build it and then
we already at build time tell you where
you have problems not at one time but
actually at build time and we can do
that because we leverage typescript
under the hood you are not a relish but
we actually have like typescript
definitions for all our AP eyes which
are basically rabbi be eyes and know
that a property is not available or like
you have some tactical hours and then
you build it and you can actually deploy
it on the right hand side you see an
emulator which is not a simulator it's
really the it maps the memory and
everything one to one has it exists on
our physical devices and there you can
run a watch face it's not the most
obvious what face here but it's done but
one of our communities our community
members which is great we also have the
ability because we have a localized ok
to tie this with your favorite idol here
I'm using webstorm that is also done the
one of our community members this is
some as you look at the structure of the
code it's he's actually inspired by C he
comes from British he background which
is fine it actually tells me that
javascript is approachable enough for c
developer whereas the other is not
operationally the case but here I'm
showing that
we actually have code completion thanks
to type on script definitions so we know
what we are dealing with we can stall
that we have at type time we know if
something is incompatible and so forth
and that is also right and because all
our projects are now like real but I do
have a package Jason they can require
other things we can now leverage all the
two legs so I can now run scripts that
are defined in the and the package.json
to build my program which is basically
the same I did previously in the command
line and also to install a ritual then
again fire up the emulator so that's
that's all great and that's basically
the same thing but i really only put
this here to show you that this is for
real and you can download it now and use
it and do javascript so here for example
that's a reimplement ation of apple
watches her massage face and there's a
third thing and we have this for a while
now it's called cloud pebble it's a
cloud-based ide traditionally for pebble
native applications where we offer you a
code editor it was previously in C now
and JavaScript and it's again the same
code it's the same author you actually
see that some of the sections are the
same and I hope that the community will
trade NPM packages from this to deal
with repetitive tasks and watch face
design the crazy thing about cloud
pebble is what it actually does because
it's not the editor is running in the
browser but we have a cloud-based build
system so whenever you actually do
something that's transmitted to the
cloud build and then the emulator you
see is also hosted on the cloud and
streamed via VNC back into the browser
where you can see the picture perfect
result but it allows you to basically
write JavaScript based applications
anywhere where you have access to a
browser to run it either in the emulator
or directly on the watch and it depends
on the remaining time to actually show
that on the actual watch so yeah that is
there and here you see that we deal with
different like screen shapes and
different aspect ratios when it comes to
our platform which is all doable that's
now let's talk about the future because
this is not the end this is not what we
want to do what we really want to do is
we want to do I'm great debugging
so here's a right now we only have
console.log for example but what you see
here is built with everything that's
publicly available on the left-hand side
see a note server which does not really
do much it's basically taking keyboard
input related via web socket to our
phone and then whenever it receives
something from the phone it prints it
out on the on the shell so I'm running
that node server and on the right hand
side there's our pebble application it
consists of two parts one is the part
that runs on the watch physically on the
watch it's trivial it's basically
whenever a message comes from the phone
eval that string take the output and
send it back so that's the watch part
and the same project also has a phone
part and the phone part is also just a
relay it talks by a WebSocket to the
node server whenever it receives a
string from the node server it forwards
it to the watch and whenever it receives
something on from the watch again it's
just our message passing here it
forwards it to the WebSocket connection
which is the node server and with that
and just a building blocks you should
all be familiar with we created on our
platform a rebel so I start this
application now again by now you should
be familiar with it it's an emulator but
now we are also printing the locks
here's the emulator and as soon as I
launch this both parts will be connected
to each other and boom there we are so
we can eval simple expressions 2+2 well
that's not really surprising but if I
lock something that log output doesn't
appear on the left hand side on my node
server but it's actually logged in the
context of of the watch and because this
is really a rocky application I can also
do everything we saw previously in the
source code so I'm now registering an
event handler that whenever it fires it
prints hello Jess conf Iceland obviously
that doesn't fire immediately because
nothing are told it to redraw but I'm
requesting now every draw and boom here
we are so this is really a node server
talking over the phone and bluetooth to
the watch printing something and Intel
terrific so we started a bit late sorry
I can you tell me how much time do we
have left awesome it's enough for me so
for the next thing I actually want to do
it for real and a live demo them because
like you saw that installing these
applications take some time because we
still do the same tool chain we
technically still build a pebble
application and under the hood there's
still a tiny little piece of see that
does nothing but telling the system okay
are cool I'm standard compliant RSV
application but you know what I don't
want to do anything but evil the
bytecode that's also part of my package
which was magically done by this mind
blowing and scripting thing before but
what if we could shortcut that even
further so we didn't know the other way
round so what you see here is yet
another watch face it's actually that is
more or less the source code of our
build and watch face and I can run this
in the browser so let me open that here
that is running in the browser although
there's no like there's no pebble
involved and you could say well that's
not a problem because the AP Isaac
handlers aren't they I can just draw to
canvas and get the result well the
problem with an environment environment
like this is that you want to have pixel
perfect results as you are developing
because the resolution is so small and
you really want to see all the quirks
and all the bugs we introduced an hour
platform so what this is is actually yes
the original source code but it lives
within an HTML page which uses a trans
piled version of our firmware inside the
browser so again we are leveraging and
scripting here but this time we trust
compiled the firmware to the application
layer of our firmware to run inside of
the browser so that we can talk to it in
the browser
and that gives me a fast feedback
because I'm now in my ID and I can say
you know what that black is a bit
depressing let's make that yellow and if
I though and if I make this and reload
that page boom it's yellow and I can
change that light to read reloaded and
there we go and then this white is
really hard to see and i'll make this
black cool so that's that's where we are
heading this is what we want to gain
right this is the development we want to
have but eventually we want to run it on
the watch so let's do that I'm copy and
pasting that into the ideally we saw
before I'm pasting it here and then you
can choose between different targets and
now taking again the emulator and while
I'm doing that to see that it actually
works taking off the launch I have you
on my wrist and put it on the video
setup i have here on the right so this
is a live camera this is actually you
here in the back and i can put my watch
here so that you can see the actual
output and by then we we started the
emulator have it all installed here and
well live demos let's see do maybe make
this black again sometimes the Radley
doesn't if I just paste maybe it didn't
understand that I was changing code and
didn't recompile really so I'm now
expecting red hands and a black
background there we are okay cool so I'm
changing that a bit more I'm saying ctx
field style is yellow and then I'm
saying ctx fill text hello Jess conf ice
land at 1010 and I'm changing that to
not talk I'm to an emulator but actually
to the phone and that is again crazy
what it does know is it understands that
my phone using my pebble account is
connected to the cloud it pushes the
binary it compiled it on the cloud and
it pushes it to the phone it talks by
bluetooth to the watch deploys it there
and what you see in the right hand side
is still the old application but I think
you got it it's now running on the watch
so this is this is really the real thing
you can write JavaScript modified and
deploy it on a launch cool so with that
I come back to my slides this was my
backup what you just saw is JavaScript
running on the watch it's really like
the real thing it's your JavaScript your
camera's code your events and everything
right there if you are a pedal developer
or I want to be deep apple developer and
see scared you in the past go there try
it out give us feedback it's it's
available if you do something with
embeddable devices and better devices
and you have a hard time thinking that
this is possible we have plenty of
internal lack knowledge and learnings
and I would love to talk to you if you
just got here by accident actually
wanted to watch the other presentation
in the other room the message to you is
you bet on the right horse javascript is
like everywhere it reaches even like
bound to those little devices and you
can be sure that javascript will be
around for a long time and there will be
more and more devices for you to play
with thanks
you